다시 돌아오신 걸 환영해요, "Quantum Computing in Practice"입니다. 저는 Olivia Lan이고요, 오늘 에피소드 3에서는
유틸리티 규모의 QAOA 실험에 집중해 볼 거예요. 처음부터 함께하셨다면 저희가
IBM 양자 하드웨어, Qiskit 패턴 프레임워크, 그리고 최신 오류 완화 기법들을 살펴보는 걸 보셨을 거예요.
연구자들과 개발자들이 양자 circuit을 확장하는 데 사용하는 것들이요. 이런 맥락을 모두 전달하는 게 정말 중요하다고 생각했어요.
방향도 보여드리고 싶었고요. 하지만 이제 이 모든 정보가 실제로
어떻게 작동하는지 보는 걸 더 미룰 이유가 없어요. 시작하기 전에 몇 가지 기억해 두실 게 있어요. 모든 것이 Qiskit
패턴 프레임워크를 따라갈 거예요. 순서대로 단계를 밟아 나갈 건데요. 1번은 문제 매핑, 2번은 circuit 최적화, 3번은
Primitives로 실행, 그리고 4번은 후처리, 즉 결과 분석이에요. 꽤 작은 예제로 시작할 거예요.
이 단계들과 그 목적을 잘 이해하실 수 있도록요. 그다음에는 비슷하지만 훨씬
큰 예제를 살펴볼 거예요. 100 qubit 수준으로 문제를 어떻게 확장하는지 보여드리려고요. 여러분 모두에게
이 강의 후에 직접 그 문제를 실행해 볼 수 있는 도구들을 드릴 거예요. 마지막으로, 이건 코드 따라가기가
아니에요. 아무리 노력해도 코드는 낡고 더 이상 안 쓰이게 되거든요. 그래서 만약 여러분이
이 영상을 출시 1년 후에 보신다면, 시간이 지나면서 조금씩 달라질 수 있는 문법에 얽매이지 않으셨으면 해요. 대신, 이건
논리와 문제 설명에 대한 자세한 논의가 될 거예요. 이 영상과 함께하는 노트북 튜토리얼이
아래 설명에 첨부되어 있어요. 코드를 따라가거나 시청 후에 참고하면서
직접 실행해 보시면 최고의 학습 경험을 하실 수 있을 거예요. 간단히 상기시켜 드리자면, 모든 계산 문제가
양자 컴퓨팅에 적합한 건 아니에요. 쉬운 문제나 단순한 계산은 이 기술을 활용할 필요가 없어요.
고전 컴퓨터가 이미 충분히 잘 풀 수 있거든요. 2024년 현재, 우리가 탐색에 가장 낙관적인
세 가지 분야는 자연 시뮬레이션, 복잡한 구조의 데이터 처리,
그리고 마지막으로 최적화예요. 최적화 문제는 계산적으로
효율적으로 풀기 가장 어려운 문제들 중 하나예요. 최적화 문제에서는 주어진 비용 함수의
최댓값이나 최솟값을 찾아야 해요. 하지만 관심 있는 많은 문제들에서 이 극값을 찾는 건
문제의 크기에 따라 지수적으로 어려워져요. 그래서 계산이 정말 어려워지는 거예요. 예를 들어,
전국에 걸친 최적 항공 경로나 배달 루트를 계산하는 게 얼마나 어려울지 상상해 보세요. 이번 강의에서는
Max Cut이라는 특정 최적화 문제를 탐구할 거예요. 이걸 양자
알고리즘인 양자 근사 최적화 알고리즘, 즉 QAOA로 풀 거예요. 그러면 Max Cut 문제가 뭐냐고요?
최대 컷 문제는 그래프 위에 정의된 조합 최적화 문제의 한 종류예요. 목표는
그래프의 꼭짓점들을 두 부분 집합으로 나눠서 두 부분 집합 사이의 엣지 수가
최대가 되도록 하는 거예요. 예를 들어, 여기 이 그래프에서 각 노드는 이렇게 연결되어 있고, Max Cut은 이 구불구불한
선으로 표시돼요. 노드를 보라색 그룹과 회색 그룹으로 나누는 거죠. 가장 많은
엣지를 가로지르는 방법은 이 그래프에서 다섯 개의 엣지를 자르는 거예요. 이 그래프는 너무 작아서
종이에서 몇 가지 컷을 시도해 보거나 머릿속으로도 다섯이 최선이라는 걸 알 수 있어요.
하지만 노드 수가 두 배, 세 배가 된다면 금방 손으로 풀기 불가능해져요.
그리고 어느 수준을 넘으면 슈퍼컴퓨터조차 최선의 답을 안정적으로 내놓기 어려워질 만큼 까다로워져요. 왜냐하면
최대 컷 수가 노드 수에 따라 지수적으로 증가하기 때문이에요. 다소 추상적으로 느껴질 수 있지만,
Max Cut 문제로 변환될 수 있는 실제 세계의 문제들이 많아요. 금융 분야의 사기 탐지, 그래프
클러스터링, 네트워크 설계, VLSI 설계, 그리고 소셜 미디어 분석 같은 것들이요.
소셜 미디어 예시는 특히 이해하기 쉬워요. 소셜 미디어 플랫폼에서 다른 사람들과 연결이 가장 많은
개인 그룹을 찾고 싶다고 해봐요. 파워 유저나
그룹에서 가장 영향력 있는 사람들을 파악하기 위해서요. 기업들이 실제로 꽤 자주 이런 걸 시도해요. 마지막으로 한 가지 더, Max Cut은 종종
더 큰 문제의 서브루틴이에요. 실제 응용을 직접 정의하는 게 아닐 수도 있지만, 내부적으로 사용되면
여러분이 막연히 생각하는 것보다 훨씬 더 흔해요. 이제 시작할 시간이에요.
첫 번째 단계는 그래프를 만드는 거예요. Python 패키지인 rustworkx를 임포트해서 할 수 있어요. 작업할
노드 수를 n으로 지정해서 정의하고, 그래프 G에 노드를 추가하세요. 엣지도
그려야 해요. 여기서는 이렇게 배열에 직접 나열할 거예요. 엣지의
가중치, 즉 지정된 두 노드가 얼마나 강하게 연결되어 있는지를 나타내는 마지막 숫자를 보여주는 방식이에요. 여기서는
모두 가중치 1로 할 거지만, 나중에 가중치를 바꿔가며 해가 어떻게 달라지는지
확인해 보시는 것도 재미있을 거예요. 가중치가 어떤 의미인지 감을 잡으려면 소셜 미디어 예시로 돌아가 볼게요.
이 가중치를 한 사람이 다른 사람에게 얼마나 영향력이 있는지로 생각할 수 있어요. 배우자나 친척과의 연결은
단순한 지인보다 아마 더 높은 가중치를 받을 거예요. 이제 그래프를 그려보세요.
첨부된 튜토리얼에 적절한 문법이 나와 있어요. 이 문제를 양자 circuit에
매핑하는 방법을 고려하기 전에, Max Cut 문제가 어떻게 최적화 문제가 되는지
맥락을 좀 쌓아봐요. 먼저 f(x)라는 함수의 최솟값을 구하는 걸 생각해 볼게요. 입력 X는
각 성분이 그래프의 각 노드에 대응하는 n차원 벡터예요. 이 함수를 앞으로
비용 함수라고 부를 거예요. 그다음에는 각 성분을 0이나
1로 제한해야 해요. 즉, 컷의 한쪽 또는 다른 쪽에 있다는 의미예요. 함수를
노드 쌍 xi와 xj로 쓸 수 있어요. 이게 해당 엣지가 컷에 있는지 알려줘요. xi + xj의 양에서
xi * xj를 뺀 값이 엣지가 컷에 있는지를 나타내요. 이 값이
1이면 엣지가 컷에 있다는 뜻이고, 0이면 없다는 뜻이에요. 컷에 있는 최대 엣지 수를 찾는 문제는
이 함수를 최대화하는 걸로 표현할 수 있어요. 다음으로, 실제로
이 함수에 전역 마이너스 부호를 추가해서 새 문제를 이 함수의 최솟값 찾기와 동등하게 만들 거예요.
대신, 이 경우 f(x)의 최솟값은 컷이 통과하는 엣지 수가
최대일 때가 될 거예요. 이 문제를 최소화 문제로 표현하는 이유는, 나중에 이걸 에너지
최소화 문제, 즉 바닥 상태 찾기로 매핑할 수 있기 때문이에요. 이게 바로 양자 컴퓨터가 자연스럽게 정말 잘하는 거거든요.
하지만 아직 양자 컴퓨팅과 관련된 건 아무것도 없다는 걸 기억하세요. 이 문제를 양자 컴퓨터가
이해할 수 있는 형태로 다시 표현해야 해요. 이제 본격적으로 작업을 시작할 준비가 됐어요.
첫 번째 단계는 문제를 양자 circuit에 매핑하는 거예요. 방금 그린 그래프에서
양자 circuit으로 어떻게 가는지 잘 안 보일 수 있지만, 천천히 살펴봐요. QAOA를 이용해
Max Cut 문제를 풀려고 한다는 걸 기억하세요. QAOA 알고리즘에서 최종적으로 원하는 건 연산자,
즉 문제의 비용 함수를 나타내는 데 사용될 해밀토니안과, 파라미터화된
circuit인 ansatz, 즉 시험 상태예요. 문제의 해에 대한 추측이나 후보가 되는 양자 상태를 나타내는 데 사용되는 거죠.
이 후보 상태들에서 샘플링한 다음,
비용 함수로 평가할 수 있어요. 이 경우 비용 함수는 f(x)인데, 이걸
양자 컴퓨터에 친숙한 방식으로 표현해야 해요. 이를 위해 일련의 수학적
변환을 활용해서 f(x)를 에너지 함수인 해밀토니안으로 표현할 거예요. 이 과정의
첫 번째 단계는 f(x)의 최소화 문제를 이차 비제약 이진 최적화
문제, 줄여서 QUBO로 표현하는 거예요. QUBO는 이런 조합 최적화 문제를 표현하는 일반적인 방법이에요.
여기서 Q는 실수로 이루어진 N×N 행렬이고, N은
그래프의 노드 수에 해당해요. 이 예시에서는 5개고요. X는 초기
공식의 이진 변수 벡터와 같아요. QAOA 알고리즘을 효과적으로 실행하려면, 최적화 문제를
해밀토니안 형태로 표현해야 해요. 해밀토니안은 시스템의 총 에너지를 나타내는 수학적 연산자예요. 구체적으로
바닥 상태 에너지, 즉 최소 고유값이
그래프 g에서 최대 컷 수를 인코딩하는 함수의 최솟값에 대응하는 비용 함수 해밀토니안을 만들고 싶어요.
이 해밀토니안을 구하면, 최적화 문제를 푸는 데 필요한 건 양자 컴퓨터에서 해밀토니안의 바닥 상태를 준비하는 것뿐이에요.
그러면 이 상태에서 샘플링하면 높은 확률로 f(x) 최소화의 해를 얻을 수 있어요. 알고 보면
운이 좋게도 QUBO 문제는 물리학에서 가장 유명하고 널리 쓰이는 해밀토니안 중 하나인
이징 해밀토니안과 매우 밀접하게 관련되어 있고 계산적으로 동등해요. QUBO 문제를
이징 해밀토니안으로 쓰려면 실제로 간단한 변수 변환만 하면 돼요.
불리언 변수 0과 1에서 스핀 변수 -1과 1로 바꾸는 거예요. 이 단계는
간단해요. 관심 있으신 분들을 위해 첨부된 노트북의 부록에 더 자세히 나와 있어요. 결국, 이 QUBO
표현의 최소화는 이 표현의 최소화와 같아요. 조금 다시 써보면
비용 함수 해밀토니안이 나와요. 이 표현의 최솟값이 바닥 상태를 나타내고, Z는
파울리 Z 연산자가 되며 b는 실수 스칼라 계수가 돼요. 해밀토니안을 구했으니,
두 개의 국소 ZZ 파울리 연산자로 쉽게 다시 쓸 수 있어요. 이게 양자 circuit에서 두 개의 큐빅 gate로
쉽게 변환돼요. 어떻게 하는지는 관련 노트북을 참고하세요. 출력은
여기 이 줄로 주어져요. 우리 예시에서는
여섯 개의 객체, 즉 파울리 문자열이 있어요. 각각이 그래프의 엣지 하나를 나타내기 때문이에요. 문자열의 길이는 노드 수와 같아요.
즉, IIIZZ는 5개의 노드를 나타내고, 문자열은
엣지에 포함된 노드의 인덱스 위치를 제외한 모든 위치에 항등원으로 구성돼요. 해당 위치엔 Z 항이 들어가죠. Qiskit에서
qubit을 나타내는 비트 문자열은 역순으로 인덱싱돼요. 예를 들어, 노드 0과 1 사이의 엣지는
IIIZZ로 인코딩돼요. 파울리 형태로 쓴 해밀토니안으로 양자 circuit을 구성할 준비가 됐어요.
이 양자 circuit은 양자 컴퓨터에서 좋은 해를 샘플링하는 데 도움을 줄 거예요. QAOA 알고리즘은
단열 정리에서 영감을 받았어요. 시간 의존적 해밀토니안의 바닥 상태에서 시작하고
해밀토니안이 충분히 천천히 진화하면 충분한 시간이 주어졌을 때 최종 상태가
최종 해밀토니안의 바닥 상태가 된다는 거예요. QAOA는 양자
단열 알고리즘의 이산 트로터 버전으로 생각할 수 있어요. 각 트로터 스텝이 P라고 부를 레이어를 나타내죠.
한 상태에서 다른 상태로 진화하는 대신, P의 각 레이어에서 비용
함수 해밀토니안과 잠시 후 더 자세히 이야기할 믹서 해밀토니안 사이를 왔다 갔다 해요. 제가 강조하고 싶은 점은
QAOA가 양자 단열 알고리즘보다 빠르다는 장점이 있지만, 최적해가 아닌 근사해를 반환한다는 거예요.
레이어 수가 무한대로 가는 극한에서 QAOA는 단열
경우에 수렴해요. 하지만 물론 이건 계산 비용이 매우 많이 들죠. 양자 circuit을 만들기 위해
gamma와 beta로 파라미터화된 교대 연산자를 적용할 거예요.
이게 시간 진화의 이산화를 나타낼 거예요. 다시 정리하면, QAOA circuit의 세 가지 주요 부분은
첫째, 회색으로 표시된 초기 시험 상태로, 이게
단열 진화의 믹서 바닥 상태예요. 모든 qubit에 Hadamard gate를 적용해서 만들죠. 둘째,
이미 갖고 있는 진한 보라색의 비용 함수 진화, 그리고 셋째, 아직 논의하지 않은
연한 보라색의 믹서 해밀토니안 아래의 진화예요. 시작 해밀토니안을
믹서라고 부르는 이유는 그 바닥 상태가 관심 있는 모든 가능한 비트 문자열의 중첩이기 때문이에요.
즉, 시작부터 모든 가능한 해의 혼합을 강제하는 거죠. 믹서 해밀토니안은 그래프의 각 노드에 대한
파울리 X 연산의 단순한 합이에요. Qiskit은 원하면 다른 커스텀 믹서 연산자를 사용하게 해주지만,
이 경우엔 표준 것을 쓸 거예요. 다시 보면, Qiskit 덕분에 많은 작업이
자동으로 처리돼서 믹서 해밀토니안과 시작 상태를 만드는 게 간단해져요. 우리가 해야 했던 작업은
비용 함수를 찾는 것뿐이었어요. 이 연산자의 각 반복을 레이어라고 불러요. 이 레이어들은
앞서 설명한 것처럼 시스템의 시간 진화를 이산화한 것으로 볼 수 있어요. 교대 패턴은
트로터 분해에서 나오고, 일반적으로 비가환 행렬의 지수 함수를 근사해요. 일반적으로 레이어나
스텝이 많을수록 연속적인 시간 진화에 더 가까워져요. 이론적으로는 결과가 더 정확해지는 거죠.
하지만 이 예시에서는 두 레이어로 샘플링을 시작할 거예요. 비용 함수 해밀토니안과
믹서 모두 파라미터화되어 있다는 걸 기억하세요. 아직 gamma와
beta의 최적값을 찾아야 해요. 정보가 정말 많았다는 거 알아요. 이런 종류의 수학을 처음 보신다면 어려울 수 있어요. 다행히 Qiskit의
멋진 점 중 하나는 방금 설명한 내용의 많은 부분이 사용자의 큰 수고 없이 자동으로 처리될 수 있다는 거예요.
내부적으로 무슨 일이 일어나는지 이해하는 게 좋긴 해요. 특히 더 큰 실험으로 확장할 때요. 하지만 매번 이 모든 작업을
직접 할 필요는 없어요. 이제 문제를 양자 circuit에 매핑했어요. 꽤 많은 작업이었지만
걱정 마세요. 할수록 더 쉬워지고 직관적이 돼요. 이제 2단계인
하드웨어에 맞게 circuit 최적화로 넘어갈 준비가 됐어요. 방금 만든 circuit이 꽤 단순해 보이고
직관적 이해를 쌓는 데 유용하지만, 양자 칩이 이 추상화된
블록을 이해하지 못한다는 걸 기억하세요. 하드웨어에 기본으로 있는 1-qubit 및 2-qubit gate의 연속으로 변환해야 해요. 여기서
"기본"이라는 말은 qubit에서 직접 수행할 수 있는 형태로 재구성된다는 의미예요. 그런 circuit들은
backend의 명령어 집합 아키텍처, 줄여서 ISA circuit으로 쓰인다고 해요.
Qiskit SDK의 transpiler 모듈은 다양한
circuit 변환을 수행할 수 있는 일련의 transpilation 패스를 제공해요. circuit이 우리 목적에 맞게
최적화되어 있는지 확인하고 싶어요. 이전 강의에서 transpilation 과정에 여러 단계가 포함된다는 걸 떠올려 보세요.
circuit의 qubit, 즉 결정 변수를 디바이스의 물리적 qubit에 매핑하고,
양자 circuit의 명령어를 backend가 실제로 이해하는 하드웨어 기본 명령어로 언롤링하고,
circuit에서 직접 상호작용하는 qubit들을 서로 인접한 물리적 qubit들로
라우팅하는 단계들이에요. 항상 그렇듯, 더 자세한 내용은 문서에서 찾을 수 있어요.
이제 어떤 backend에서 circuit을 실행할지 선택하는 흥미로운 단계가 왔어요. 실제로 이 과정을
transpilation 단계 전에 해야 해요. transpiler가 프로세서에 따라 다르게 최적화하기 때문이에요. 이게 Qiskit이 이 단계의 많은 부분을
자동화할 수 있다는 게 중요한 또 다른 이유예요. circuit을 직접 손으로 최적화하고 싶지 않으실 거예요.
가능하긴 하지만 때로는 까다롭고 시간이 많이 걸려요. 결국 다른 속성을 가진
다른 프로세서에서 circuit을 실행하고 싶다는 걸 깨닫고 모든 작업을 다시 해야 할 수도 있으니까요. 선택한
backend를 transpiler 함수에 넘기고 최적화 수준을 지정하는 걸 잊지 마세요.
이번에는 가장 높고 가장 철저한 최적화인 최적화 레벨 3을 선택했어요.
2단계는 그게 전부예요. circuit이 자동으로 transpile되었고, 1-qubit 및 2-qubit gate로
어떻게 변환되었는지 볼 수 있도록 여기에 그려봤어요. 이제 3단계인
Qiskit Primitives로 circuit 실행할 시간이에요. 지금까지 gamma와 beta 파라미터를
그대로 둔 채 circuit을 transpile했어요. 하지만 이 파라미터 값을 지정하지 않고는 circuit을 실제로 실행할 수 없어요. QAOA
워크플로우에서 최적의 QAOA 파라미터는 반복적인 최적화 루프에서 찾아요. 일련의 circuit
평가를 실행하고 고전 최적화기를 사용해서 최적의 beta와 gamma 파라미터를 찾는 거예요. 하지만 어딘가에서
시작해야 하니까, Gamma 1, Gamma 2에는 π/2, Beta 1, Beta 2에는 π를
초기 추정값으로 설정했어요. 또한, gamma와 beta의 더 좋은 해를 찾기 위해 최적화기를 사용할 거라는 점도
알아두세요. 지금은 두 레이어만 계산하고 있어서 그게 전부지만, 더 정확한 QAOA circuit을 만든다면
레이어를 더 추가하게 될 거고, 그러면 각 순차적
레이어마다 최적화된 gamma와 beta가 필요해요. 잠깐 멈춰서 Primitives 옵션을 떠올려볼게요. estimator와
sampler가 있어요. 이런 종류의 작업에 어떤 걸 사용할 것 같으세요? 어떤 걸 생각하셨든
사실 둘 다 맞아요. estimator와 sampler 모두 사용할 거거든요. 초기 최적화
루프에는 estimator가 필요하지만, 나중에 최종
해를 읽어내는 데는 sampler를 사용할 거예요. 이제 알고리즘을 실행할 준비가 거의 다 됐어요, 정말이에요. 하지만 아주 빠르게, 작업을
다양한 방식으로 보낼 수 있다는 걸 짚고 넘어가야 해요. 이걸 실행 모드라고 해요. 먼저 job 모드는
context manager 없이 만든 estimator나 sampler의 단일 primitive 요청이에요. circuit과 입력은 primitive
통합 블록, 즉 PUB로 패키징되어 양자
컴퓨터의 실행 태스크로 제출돼요. batch 모드는 독립적인 여러 job으로 구성된 실험을 효율적으로 실행하기 위한 다중 job 관리자예요.
여러 primitive job을 동시에 제출하려면 batch 모드를 사용하세요. session 모드는 다중 job 워크로드를 실행하기 위한 전용
윈도우예요. 프리미엄 사용자가 변분 알고리즘을 더 예측 가능한 방식으로 실험하고
스택의 병렬성을 활용해서 여러 실험을 동시에 실행할 수도 있어요.
반복적인 워크플로우와 전용 접근이 필요한 실험에는 session을 사용하세요. QAOA 실험의 경우,
접근 권한이 있다면 session이 좋은 선택이에요. beta와
gamma의 여러 값에 대해 여러 circuit을 시도해야 하기 때문이에요. 이제 최적화 문제로 돌아가 봐요. 이미
비용 함수 해밀토니안 HC를 정의했고, 전체 워크플로우는 이래요. QAOA
알고리즘은 중첩 상태의 qubit을 초기화하고 P 레이어로 ansatz를 적용해요.
gamma와 beta 파라미터를 초기화한 다음 estimator primitive를 사용해서 circuit을 실행해요.
기댓값을 계산하면 COBYLA라는 SciPy 최적화기를 사용할 거예요. COBYLA는
QPU 외부에서 고전적으로 비용 함수를 최적화해요. gamma와 beta 값이 업데이트되면
반복해요. 전체 비용 함수의 값이 수렴해서 최솟값에 도달할 때까지 이걸 반복할 거예요.
그다음 이 낮은 비용 값에 해당하는 gamma와 beta 값을 선택해서 circuit을 마지막으로
한 번 더 실행할 거예요. 이번엔 sampler를 사용해서요. 이게 제가 초기 추정값으로 COBYLA 최적화기를 실행한 결과예요. 반복 수행에 따른
비용 함수 값이 처음엔 좀 불안정하고 오르내리다가
낮은 값으로 안정되는 걸 볼 수 있어요. 최소 비용 함수 평가에 해당하는
마지막 gamma와 beta 값을 사용해서 circuit을 마지막으로 한 번 실행하고, Max Cut을 줄 비트 문자열을
샘플링할 거예요. 이제 최적화된 gamma와 beta 값으로 circuit을 마지막으로 한 번 실행해서
sampler를 사용해 가능한 최선의 비트 문자열을 찾을 거예요. 제가 여기서 사용하는 구체적인 값들을 나열했지만, 직접 시도하거나
같은 튜토리얼 노트북을 다시 실행할 때 이 값들이 조금 달라질 수 있다는 걸 기억하세요. 이제
이 값들로 최적화된 circuit을 실행하고 Max Cut 문제의 후보 해를 찾을 거예요. session을
사용하고 있었다면 이제 마지막 job 하나만 실행하니까 더 이상 필요 없어요. 이제 드디어
후처리 단계와 최종 해 찾기를 살펴볼게요. 먼저
비트 문자열로 변환한 모든 가능한 노드 조합을 히스토그램으로 그려봐요. 제가 실행했을 때
네 가지 해를 찾았고, 다른 어떤 해보다 더 가능성이 높은 것들을 보라색으로 강조했어요.
가장 높고 따라서 가장 가능성 높은 비트 문자열 해는 0 1 0 1이에요. 플롯에서 qubit의 순서가
역순임에 주의하세요. 가장 가능성 높은 해를 보면 노드 0과 3이 함께 그룹화되고
마찬가지로 노드 1, 2, 4도 그룹화된다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 드디어 가장 가능성 높은
비트 문자열을 그래프로 다시 그릴 수 있어요. 비트 문자열은 단순히 노드 번호에 해당해요. 그리고 1로 표시되면
그룹에 포함되고, 0으로 표시되면 포함되지 않는 거예요. 컷을 그리면 이제 눈으로
최선의 컷에 대한 근사 선을 볼 수 있어요. 다섯 노드 모두의 이상적인 그룹화를 나타내는데, 여기에 그려봤어요.
하지만 여기서 한 가지 시간을 들여 이야기하고 싶은 건, 올바른 해가 유일하지 않다는 사실이에요.
이 그래프의 대칭성 때문에 여러 개의 올바른 해가 있어요. 노드 0과 3이 컷 안에 있는 대신
노드 2와 4가 포함될 수도 있어요. 컷을 회전해서
이 새로운 점들을 포함하기만 하면 돼요. 다섯이라는 해는 그대로예요.
히스토그램과 가장 가능성 높은 네 가지 해를 잠깐 다시 살펴봐요. 마지막 두 해는
방금 그린 것들로, 똑같이 정확해요. 하지만 그게 전부가 아니에요. 모든
올바른 해에 대해 색상을 반전시킬 수도 있어요. 이번엔 노드를 컷 안쪽이냐 바깥쪽이냐로만 생각하면 돼요.
이전 슬라이드에서 두 가지 고유한 올바른 해를 찾았지만, 실제로는 해가 두 개 더 있어요. 각각에 대한
반전에 해당하는 것들이요. 나머지 두 해를 그렸을 때 제가 한 건 단지 색상을 반전한 것뿐이에요.
문제는 알고리즘이 이 네 번째 마지막 해를
상위 네 가지 가능성 높은 답 중 하나로 찾거나 식별하지 못했다는 거예요. 다섯 번째였어요. 알고리즘이 식별한 네 번째 해는
실제로 틀렸어요. 그려보면 그 해는 컷이 네 개뿐이에요. 다른 해들은
다섯 개인데, 넷은 명확히 다섯보다 작으니까 명백히 틀린 거죠. 여기서 요점은
이게 근사 알고리즘이라는 거예요. 틀릴 수 없는 게 아니고, 100% 정확하지도 않아요. 해를
자신의 지식과 이해로 검증하는 과정이 필요해요. 이 오류는 여러 곳에서 발생할 수 있다는 걸
짚고 넘어갈 가치가 있어요. 알고리즘 자체의 근사적 특성과 제가 선택한 적은
레이어 수 때문일 수도 있고, 실험의 shot 수를 늘리면 줄일 수 있는 유한 샘플링 오류일 수도 있어요.
또는 네 번째 실제 해가 단 1비트만 다르기 때문에 readout 오류일 수도 있어요.
이 모든 가능성들을 짚는 이유는, 이게 양자 컴퓨팅의 진정한
실천가가 되기 위해 필요한 것들이기 때문이에요. 하드웨어의 성능과 이게 어떻게 특정 유형의 오류에 기여하는지,
그리고 어떻게 수정하는지를 이해해야 해요. 하지만, 32가지 가능한 비트 문자열 해 중에서
네 가지 실제 해가 상위 다섯 후보에 모두 포함됐다는 걸 잊지 마세요.
두 레이어만 사용해서 이걸 찾았어요. 일반적으로 매번 최선의 Max Cut을 찾을 가능성을 높이고 싶다면
레이어 깊이를 늘리면 돼요. 여기에 미묘한 점들이 있지만, 그건 다음
에피소드에서요. 이제 직접 시도해 볼 시간이에요. 하지만 이번엔 100
qubit을 사용할 거예요. 100 qubit 그래프를 그리면, 더 이상 Max Cut이 어디서 발생할지
눈으로 파악하는 게 직관적이지도 가능하지도 않다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 직접 찾아내기엔 가능성이 너무 많아요. 하지만
QAOA로 이 문제를 푸는 건 여전히 완전히 가능하고, 5
qubit에 사용한 것과 완전히 동일한 워크플로우를 따라갈 수 있어요. 이제 혼자 보내드리려 하는데, 이 실험을 시도해 보시기 전에
정리해 볼게요. QAOA job의 여섯 단계는 다음과 같아요. 1. 바닥 상태가 최적화 문제의 해를 인코딩하는
비용 해밀토니안 정의, 2. 믹서 해밀토니안 정의, 3. 지수화된
해밀토니안에 해당하는 연산자 구성, 4. circuit 구축. 믹서의 초기 바닥 상태와
비용 함수의 반복적인 교대 레이어와 믹서 해밀토니안 아래의 진화로 구성돼요. 5. 초기 상태 준비와
고전 컴퓨팅 기법으로 파라미터 최적화, 6. circuit 실행, 출력 비트 문자열 측정,
가장 가능성 높은 해 탐색이에요. 여기서 몇 가지 참고할 점들이 있어요.
5 qubit 예시에서 최적화 레벨 3을 사용했지만, 꼭 필요한 건 아니었을 수 있어요. 5 qubit의 경우
circuit 깊이가 꽤 낮아서 더 낮은 최적화 수준에서도 대부분 올바른 답이 나올 수 있어요.
하지만 100 qubit과 큰 circuit 깊이에서는 거의 확실히 가장 높은 최적화 수준이
올바른 답을 찾는 데 필요해요. 또한, 일반적인 유틸리티 규모 워크플로우에서 가장 도전적인 부분 중 하나는
매핑 단계와 IBM의 heavy hex 토폴로지에 잘 대응하는 그래프를 찾는 것임을 기억하세요.
처음부터 이 작업을 하신다면 틀림없이 많은 시간을 거기에 쏟게 될 거예요. 지금은 이 부분이
여러분을 위해 처리해 놨어요. 이 실습의 주요 목적이 아니니까요. 하지만 이건 연습이 필요하고
대규모 job을 실행하는 게 항상 간단하진 않다는 걸 명심하세요. 에피소드 4에서
더 자세히 살펴볼게요. 최종 circuit은 5 qubit에서 실행한 circuit보다 훨씬 복잡해 보일 거예요.
하지만 한편으로는, 이 circuit을 보면서 gate가 얼마나 많은지 알고, 이걸 실제 양자
프로세서에서 실제로 실행할 수 있는 능력이 있다는 게
꽤 인상적이라고 생각해요. 이게 제 최종 해예요. 알고리즘이 분명히 이
노드들을 두 그룹으로 묶을 수 있고, 두 집합을 나누는 최선의 Max Cut을 찾을 수 있다는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
두 집합에서 Max Cut 선으로 가는 건 간단해요. 노드를 연결하는 선을 따라 색상이 바뀌는 곳이
Max Cut 선이 그려져야 할 위치를 나타내요. 제가 실행했을 때 달성한 Max Cut 값은
84였어요. 직접 시도해 보시고 댓글에 비슷한 결과를 얻었는지 알려주세요. 레이어 세 개, 아니면 네 개를 시도해 보거나,
노드 간 가중치를 바꿔서 결과가 어떻게 달라지는지 보세요. QAOA로 실행할 수 있는
흥미로운 실험들이 정말 많아요. 제가 방금 가능한 최선의 해를 찾은 게 보장되지 않는다는 걸 기억하세요.
좋은 해라는 건 알지만, 재미 삼아 저를 이겨보는 도전을 해보세요. 84보다 더 좋은 걸 얻을 수 있는지 보세요.
결론적으로, QAOA는 매우 역동적인
알고리즘이고 탐구해야 할 휴리스틱과 내용이 많아요. 일반적인 최적화 분야에 대해
새로운 것들을 배울 여지가 많죠. 최근 최적화 분야에서 많은 연구가 이루어지고 있어요.
QAOA나 최적화에 관해 최근 온라인에 게시된 아카이브 논문들이 이를 잘 보여주죠. 정말 흥미로운 건
이제 이 논문들이 모두 이론 논문만은 아니라는 거예요. 이론가들은 수년간 QAOA를 연구해 왔지만,
이제 실험가들도 참여하고 있어요. 마침내 IBM 프로세서처럼 이런 실험들을 실행할 수 있는
하드웨어가 생겼기 때문이에요. 상상의 공간에서 현실 세계로 나아가고 있어요.
그게 정말 흥미롭죠. 아직 해야 할 일이 많고 해결해야 할 오류들도 많지만,
빠르게 진전하고 있어요. 이 영상을 여기까지 보신 여러분은 이런 실험들을 직접
실행할 수 있어요. 100 qubit 실험을 직접 실행해 보시고 어떻게 됐는지 알려주세요.
튜토리얼을 따라하시면 잘 될 거예요. 궁금한 점이 생기거나 막히더라도 걱정 마세요.
처음 배울 때 저도 그랬고 같은 질문들을 했어요.
최선을 다해보시고 어떤 질문이 생기는지 알려주세요. 다음에 또 만나요.
[음악]